good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
message is schedule your time over to
you Tim Farriss large uninterrupted
blocks of time you have to schedule if
you are a creator blocks of time that
are at least two to four hours or more
no Frankenstein's monster of 20 minute
breaks and ten minute breaks combined
into three hours will have the value of
an uninterrupted block of three hours if
you are trying to make high-level
decisions focus on time-consuming
high-priority projects push something to
a next milestone we all have the same 24
hours in the day and if you're like I
don't have time I can't sleep I need to
cut back on sleep I need to do this I
need to do that if you don't have time
you don't have priorities that's it I
never use I don't have time as a reason
for not to do something I'm allergic to
it as soon as you start saying I don't
have time to do something then you're
giving responsibilities to way to
something else right you don't have time
it's not your fault
you just don't have the time it's it's
somebody else's fault this this projects
filed this person's fault it's always
somebody else's fault until you take
control of your responsibilities and
your priorities and managing your own
time you're never going to go off and do
the big things that you want to do
especially for the people who complain
that you have this big goal in this big
dream you want to build this huge
company and then you're not doing it
you're not spending a time to do it cuz
it's so great to live up in our heads of
all the things that we want to do of the
passions and the the way that our life
could look but you don't want to do the
actual work to get there and now I get
it I get I'm a father I'm a husband I
have three businesses that I run at the
same time I'm a busy guy but if I want
to work on something and I can't then
it's my problem
right it's it's nobody else's promise
not you guys it's not it's not believed
nation expecting my video to come out I
choose to make youtube videos I choose
to do three a day I choose to spend my
time on these things and by very
definition by choosing to do something
you're choosing not to do something else
I have control you have control over
your time as well and their realities of
paying the bills and family life and all
of that stuff and it may may force you
to make some difficult decisions but as
soon as you say I don't have time it
means you're never gonna make it because
you're never gonna have time this the
people will constantly live in in when
this clears up right when this thing
goes away then I'll have time and then
when that clears away something else
comes up when that's done then I'll have
time and then you never have time it's
never the perfect time you just have to
go and start doing it nothing actually
starts happening until you put it into
your calendar you start taking action
otherwise review is living in your head
and those dreams never come out and so I
would encourage you to any time you say
I don't have time to catch yourself and
say I choose not to make it a priority
this is not a priority in my life when
you start embracing that and actually
feeling it and you'll start making some
important decisions on how you schedule
the time start to think what actually is
a priority to you start making some
tweaks you start to see some big changes
happening in your life and in your
business
now the Tim's point about creating the
schedule one of the things that I find
really helpful is chunking my time I've
talked about this before but I like
having dedicated days to do dedicated
things so you know I film once a month
for my YouTube channel for the most part
and we come in on a Wednesday and film
everything in one sitting and I mean I'm
in video mode I find it really hard to
switch tasks I think most people do but
I just find it really hard I can't go
from meeting with somebody for half an
hour to then writing a book for half an
hour to then get into the phone call for
half an hour to then recording the video
for half an hour I just the switching
costs are too high if I'm gonna write my
book or do something else that's really
creative I need half an hour to 40
minutes just to get into it before I'm
actually really creating some
good it's why when I make my videos here
I start with the easy stuff first and
then I lead to the in spresso x' because
it allows me to warm up to get going if
I had to come in and boom just drop it
and spread so it'd be a lot more
challenging for me and so anything you
do multiple times per week try to do
months per week multiple times per month
once per month and so on multi a day
once per day right like email social
media if you're doing that all day long
do that once per day it means that you
miss out on some small things it means
that you miss out on getting some
opportunities maybe some reporter wants
to interview and has a deadline by 3:00
p.m. today and you don't open that email
until five o'clock you've missed it but
you have to be willing to let go of the
little to be able to go for the big and
I used to pride myself as the guy who
responded to email super fast you sent
me an email like two minutes later boom
response I would drop whatever I was
doing to respond to your email and what
it meant was I was doing lots of little
tasks really quickly but I never got to
focus on the big tasks because they kept
getting distracted and so by checking
your time and by blocking off access in
your calendar it means you'll have to
say no to something some little projects
some things will slip through but you're
spending your time on the big projects
that matter and so it's been probably
the single most important time
management skill practice that I've
applied is chunking your time having one
main thing that I do every single day so
you know Wednesday is recording YouTube
videos and when I'm not doing that it's
my Lily day where we're looking at her
Channel Thursday is my public-facing day
and we're doing interviews and podcasts
and radio shows and YouTube channels and
just extrovert mode Monday is my tds
days from here and working with alex who
working through all the problems that we
have to do with TBS looking at
opportunities where we're gonna grow
them just in tds mindset right so every
day i'm doing something else but it also
means i I will delay something so if
it's something tedious related and Alex
send it to me on Tuesday I'm probably
not going to get it to next Monday and
so part of that is training the team to
say hey we got to get it done on time so
I can handle it at the right moment but
also means that sometimes we may
windows of opportunities because I
haven't seen it but nah it's not gonna
come up again till Monday and being okay
with that being okay with dropping some
small balls so you can keep the big ones
in the air so the question today today
is I'm curious how are you scheduling
your time
do you prefer to have full days or full
afternoons dedicated to one thing at a
time or do you like the variety and the
mix-up and spending half an hour and one
thing and then moving to something else
I really curious apparently your habits
leave it on the comments below super
curious see we have to say and if you
leave a comment in the first few hours
is free to go in live you have a chance
to win one of our two daily prizes I
also want to give a quick shout-out to
Dilip Gil out thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book your one
word and taking that picture and sharing
it with me I love the background of
Moana actually haven't seen that movie
yet both Nina and Hayden have seen it
and they don't want to watch it again
and so I you have to wash it by myself
or force somebody to watch it with me I
don't like watching cartoons myself so
that's the only issue we'll see how it
goes but thank you so much for picking
up a copy of the book and for sharing it
I really appreciate the support thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
[Music]
you know I'm very methodical about time
management because it's so hard to do so
the first thing I can I'll give you a
couple of important life changing tips
for ne1 try to do something creative on
the computer so number one thing there's
a is no email in the morning like number
one thing is there's a program called
freedom that I downloaded then and it
says yeah I love the word freedom
because that's really what it is it says
how many minutes of freedom do you want
you say whatever it is 90 minutes and
then you cannot actually access the
internet for 90 minutes there's no
unlock code people are gasping you're
all gonna use it yeah
there's no unlock codes the first thing
I do is a is foam I give to someone else
or put it in a drawer somewhere it's
best if I give it to someone else
internet goes off and I commit to that
amount of a certain amount of time so my
thing is that is compartmentalizing that
even check your email check it from 4:00
to 5:00 they have there's a someone
wrote a book which I never read but it's
called never check your email in the
morning you don't I don't know if you
agree or not but just know the title and
it's really great it's great the thing
is with time is to become proactive
about time instead of reactive because I
know so many people you can't do
anything because you're getting a you
know message on Facebook and then you're
getting a you know an email and then
you're just reacting to that because it
feels like you were getting something
done at the end of the day you got
nothing done yeah so I what my thing is
I'm really and everyone knows that I'm
proactive about that two-degree that um
by the way I'd have Facebook and Twitter
blocked on my computer what I did is I
downloaded Antigo content because it
content bury whatever it is there's no
time can be used it yeah net net is like
a block specific site yeah and I had
someone else put in their password for
those sites so I don't even know the
password so I couldn't get to Twitter or
Facebook if I'd tried so finding those
things that are those are those and
putting walls between you and them or
limiting them in certain ways there's
one other thing was gonna say was them
Oh which is friends can be a pain in the
ass if you're trying to be creative and
if you have more than seven friends I
never want to see one day a week what do
you do so another thing I want to say is
that I do a a Wednesday night dinner
party yeah so if my friends want to see
me I'm like right Wednesday someone
wants a meeting I'm not sure about
Wednesday night so Wednesday night we we
all go to a restaurant and and basically
whoever I want to see or catch up on
I'll see them there and then maybe
afterward I'll break off and my closer
friends but that way I can see everyone
people who want to meet with but I don't
want to really take the time for a lunch
or meeting one-on-one I just bring them
there if I like them I talk to a bunch
if I don't like far away I mean depends
if I have some time off I always take
time for music so it for me it's
different I think but when I'm touring
everyday I have actually more routine
than when I'm not touring everyday so
it's it's like because you have to you
have to have your schedule so you really
have to plan your day well but if I have
six weeks off I'm pretty much all over
the place you know you yeah you don't
really have a schedule so you be just do
whatever yeah and you waste time yeah
but if you have a really military
schedule then you have to really plan
everything well so that works better for
me actually